alors ce ciblage des symboles est ce qu
on mélange tout n'est ce pas contre
productif le racisme n'est t'il pas
universelle
c'est l'objet de notre face à face et
pour en débattre nous sommes en direct
avec louis georges tin ancien président
du cran conseil représentatif des
associations noires de france bonsoir
louis georges tin merci d'être avec nous
ses côtés pour la 30e quelle
contradiction au clément martin porte
parole de générations identitaire
bonsoir vous aussi merci d'être avec
nous alors négrophobie d'état un tag et
sur la statue de colbert devant
l'assemblée nationale
ça fait un petit peu mauvais genre est
ce que ça vous chante que chaque cas
clément martin déjà l'expression des
gros fox d'état le choc
oui bien évidemment déjà ne serait ce
que parce que je ne vois pas comment on
peut parler de ça à l'heure où la france
afrique à nice tous les jours un peu
plus et cela est un permis justement par
l'état et la politique migratoire qui
est mise en place
donc ça me paraît être quelque chose de
complètement décalé en réalité le
négrophobie d'état et un racisme d'état
qui donc permettrait par exemple que 52
% des allocataires de la caf soit des
étrangers par exemple ou bien là on a pu
voir récemment que le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner s'est
soumis littéralement ou mouvement black
light matters et au collectif à damas
est par ailleurs d'ailleurs le collectif
à damas qui a fait des manifestations
qui était donc absolument pas autorisés
et pour autant l'état donc on a décidé
qu'il ne fallait pas poursuivre aucun
des organisateurs donc parler de négoce
d'état dans ces conditions me paraît
complètement loufoque et grotesque pour
être tout à fait sincère avec vous on va
laissez pas la parole à louis georges
tin qui ne va pas manquer j'imagine de
vous répondre répondre oui georges atta
oui mon interlocuteur a déjà
appartiennent associations qui étaient
condamnées plusieurs fois pro citation à
l'aération adorent n'est pas tout à fait
surpris de son discours revenons fait
préparez le cotnoir d'organiser lui
aussi sans qui a créé je faisais pas
interrompu donc c'est aussi lui qui a
créé la compagnie des indes qui a
déporté des milliers d'africains sur la
été reconnue par la loi taubira comme
étant un crime contre l'humanité et dont
je m'étonne que l'on puisse célébrer
quelqu'un qui est l'auteur d'un double
crime contre l'humanité devant
l'assemblée nationale
je rappelle que les valeurs de notre
pays c'est liberté égalité fraternité et
sont inscrits finalement à l'assemblée
nationale or colbert c'était l'ennemi de
la liberté
c'étaient les nuits de l'égalité c'était
l'ennemi de la fraternité
et je rappelle aussi que le parlement à
l'époque s'est opposée au co noir le
parlement a dit cela est contraire au
droit français au droit naturel et au
droit divin donc en fait on met devant
la statue de l'assemblée devant
l'assemblée une statue qui représente
quelqu'un qui a violé l'humanité qui a
violé les droits de la france et qu'elle
violait les droits du parlement
c'est une contradiction absolument
invraisemblable alors clément martin
votre réponse parce que vous avez
essayer d'interpeller effectivement
louis georges tin mais voulait c'est
donc à lui lui poser la question vous
souhaitiez dû poser tout à l'heure non
mais je vais revenir ce qu'il ya dans
son jardin qui a été offert et je me
permets de réagir génération identitaire
d'achat n'ait été condamné pour
incitation à la haine raciale est
d'ailleurs lorsque cela avait été le cas
pour l'action que nous avions faite sur
le chantier de la mosquée de poitiers en
première instance il ya les tuer
effectivement cette condamnation
nous venons il ya quelques jours d'être
intégralement blanchi il ya eu une
relation néral donc alors il ya
plusieurs dossiers
j invite les téléspectateurs à regarder
la fiche wikipédia des médias et votre
cv j'ai envie de dire judiciaire autres
cases et du cher est long comme un jour
sans pain
enfin ce n'est pas le débat revenant sur
ses pas le débat alors le grand public
effectivement machine vous connais pas
nécessairement on précise un vous
faisiez partie 2 de ces jeunes qui se
sont retrouvés sur les toits de la place
de la république il ya une dizaine de
jours a déployé une banderole contre le
racisme anti blanc au moment justement
il y avait ces rassemblements contre les
violences policières tel message vous
vouliez faire passer c'était une forme
de provocation vous vouliez vraiment
véhiculer un message sérieux
elle était déjà la première provocation
c'était peut-être davantage la tenue de
cette manifestation
autant quand même dû coronavirus est
donc une manifestation qui n'a rien
n'était pas autorisée ça c'est un
premier point la deuxième prolongation
par le ministre de l'intérieur elle a
été tolérée au nom de l'émotion a dit
christophe autorisé dire ce n'est pas
les deux en même temps s'il vous plaît
merci donc est également la provocation
c'était peut-être également les insultes
antisémites et les insultes de sales
blancs qui ont visé nos militants qui
ont fait cette action place de la
république
peut-être que la vraie provocation était
celle ci par contre après je vais être
très clair avec vous je pourrais vous
dire ils ont fait leurs manifestations
nous avons fait notre action et après
tout chacun a le droit de s'exprimer et
c'est clairement nous nous avons une
stratégie qui était ne piratez cet
événement car il y avait une attention
médiatique qui était totalement
disproportionnées par rapport à la
réalité des faits d'ailleurs à la
réalité de la mobilisation puisque cette
mobilisation alors qu'elles avaient été
annoncées durant une semaine dans tous
les médias a fait en réalité moins de
manifestants que la précédente
et donc nous nous avons profité de
l'attention médiatique totalement
exagéré disproportionnée sur cet
événement pour justement mettre la
thématique du racisme anti blanc au
centre du jeu car effectivement cette
thématique est très rarement traités
dans les médias ou bien pour dire
qu'elle n'existe pas et ça c'est quelque
chose que nous avons réussi et c'est
quelque chose dont nous sommes très
fiers car cette opération a été un
succès par rapport à cela louis georges
tin en tout cas ça a le mérite de poser
la question effectivement les gros
phobie d'état c'est ce qui figurait sur
cette statue de colbert est ce que selon
vous le racisme ne concerne que les
noirs n'est-il pas universelle au moins
je suis heureux de constater que mon
interlocuteur reconnaît avoir une
stratégie de brazil c'est ce qui l'a dit
lui même alors sur le racisme anti blanc
c'est une stratégie de diversion vous
savez il ya beaucoup d'hommes qui nous
explique vraiment que le sexisme contre
lui
home est une chose très dur à vivre je
suis un homme soyons honnêtes le sexisme
en france c'est la domination des femmes
par les hommes du racisme évidemment il
ne faut pas renverser les rôles il faut
pas dire les choses à l'envers
évidemment ce sont des stratégies de
diversion on les comprend mais enfin il
faut remettre les choses à l'endroit
je n'ai pas eu connaissance qu'il y ait
eu un crime contre l'humanité contre les
blancs en france je n'ai pas eu
connaissance qu'il y ait eu un colbert
qui pratiquent l esclavage en france
contre eux oui mais justement la shoah
c'est précisément précisément contre des
populations qui est estimée être d'une
race différente c'est à la négrophobie
d'état effectivement satgé statut donc
ça a peut-être un peu le champ du
racisme mais parce que c'est un sujet
par du théâtre madame il faut
effectivement le traité quand on a une
statue de colbert devant l'assemblée
nationale c'est le sujet qui est posé et
donc on a besoin en effet de dire qu' il
y a là une atteinte aux droits de
l'homme et qui est caractérisée c'est à
dire que dans certains cas le racisme et
de l'antisémitisme s'appelle de
l'islamophobie lassé de la négrophobie
dont c'est le terme technique employée
vous savez madame bachelet qui est la
haut commissaire aux droits de l'homme a
parlé sur ces questions il ya encore du
jour en disant très clairement à quel
point les nations unies devaient
s'engager sur ces questions de racisme
notamment sur celui là mais comme tous
les autres racisme évidemment elle a
parlé de réparations et la partie
devient extrêmement fort et je crois
qu'il faut aller dans ce sens je
rappelle que l'union européenne a
d'ailleurs rappelé que dit effectivement
les pays européens doivent mettre en
place des politiques de restitution et
de réparation c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le parlement européen avec une
majorité conservatrice
mais même en europe avec une majorité
conservatrice on a pris conscience de
certaines banques de nécessité en termes
de justice et donc c'est cela
aujourd'hui qu'il faut mettre sur la
table qu'il y ait des gens qui fassent
un peu de diversion un peu de bruit si
ça les amuse pourquoi pas
l'important c'est que nous on puisse
avancer et c'est la france qui avance
sur les valeurs républicaines liberté
égalité fraternité
alors parmi les détracteurs certains ont
proposé tout simplement le déboulonnage
de ce genre de statut je vous propose
d'écouté si bête en diana porte parole
du gouvernement qui ne sont pas partager
cet avis écoutez je dénonce avec fermeté
ce qu'ils veulent effacer des traits de
notre histoire
je crois qu'il est important que nous
ayons un regard lucide et apaisée sur
les personnages les faits historiques
tels qu'ils se sont déroulés
effectivement clément martin ne pas
déboulonner ce genre de statut mais
important de rappeler d'expliquer
l'histoire vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse de la porte parole a accueilli
aussi quelque chose en fait c'est que
c'est assez la vie de la porte parole du
gouvernement
mais c'est la vie en fait de beaucoup
d'autres personnes ça a été d'ailleurs
aussi l'avis de julien dray même fondé
sos racisme et qui n'est absolument pas
favorable non plus au fait de
déboulonner la statue de colbert et
d'ailleurs il a même dit que si on
devait recontextualiser les choses il en
réalité
le code droit pouvait être compris dans
le contexte de l'époque comme un progrès
et c'est lui l'a dit en l'occurrence ce
n'est pas moi invités je vous invite à
les sociétés il s'en est excusé la fille
hilare et qu'il a reculé là dessus il a
remarqué c'était une erreur et dont vous
pouvez pas évoqué ce propos sans dire
qu'elle a rectifié après ben avant tout
les temps je peux enfin soyons les seuls
propos d'ailleurs insisté à dire qu'il y
avait énormément de gens qui étaient de
cet avis et il ya notamment eu
d'ailleurs un sondage de l'ifop qui a
démontré que 76% des français était tout
à fait hostile à cette volonté de
déboulonner les statues
donc en réalité c'est le fruit d'une
minorité d'une minorité activistes qui
souhaite imposer ses choix à la majorité
des français est louis georges tin le
mot de la fin pour vous vous comprenez
qu'une majorité de français n'est pas
nécessairement envie qu on déboulonne
une partie de son histoire même s'il ya
parfois peut-être des zones de mourad
ombre mais qu'elle préfère peut-être
justement expliqué un histoire et ne pas
la gommer mais nous ne voulons pas du
tout est fait c'est l'histoire au
contraire ce sont les militants comme
nous qui faisons en sorte que l'on
puisse parler de cette histoire l'état
en revanche a souvent voulu cacher ses
crimes coloniaux donc que monsieur macro
nous disent il faut pas effacer
l'histoire je deale un peu gonflé car
c'est précisément l'état qui a souvent
occulter l'histoire et c'est des gens
comme tout comme madame taubira qui ont
permis de mieux connaître cette histoire
quand nous parlons de gallieni qui
connaît gagné en france très peu de gens
il a écrit la politique de la race et la
massacrer des gens dans toutes les
colonies mais c'est grâce à notre combat
que cette histoire est connue
donc moi je ne dis pas par exemple qu'il
faille des boulonnais et casser la
statue il faut la mettre au bon endroit
le bon endroit c'est un musée de
l'esclavagé est donc là elle sera
respectée on expliquera mais vous ne
pouvez pas la mettre comme ça devant
l'assemblée nationale c'est un
contresens historique c'est une insulte
et moi je dis y compris à des gens
conservateur monsieur vous aimez la
france comme moi je dis comment
pouvons-nous faire france dans un pays
où les bourreaux des uns sont les héros
des autres voilà c'est le message que
voudrait tout est représenté de la fin
merci louis georges tin merci également
à clément martin d'avoir accepté ce
débat